AND THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE,
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: DAVID DORAN IS NOT
A NAME ON THE LIPS OF OUR
LEADERS THIS WEEK.
SHOULD BE.
HE SERVED HIS COMMUNITY FOR
ALMOST 30 YEARS AS A POLICE
OFFICER.
EVEN AFTER HE RETIRED HE
CONTINUE TO HELP OTHERS.
LAST WEEKEND, HE WAS IN LEWIS
TRYING TO PROTECT A FRIEND’S
STORE FROM LOOTERS AND HE WAS
MURDERED FOR DOING IT.
THIS COUNTRY OUGHT TO REMEMBER
HIM.
HE REPRESENTS THE BEST OF
AMERICA.
INSTEAD, HIS NAME HAS BEEN
SHOVED DOWN THE MEMORY HOLE.
THE MEDIA WOULD LIKE AND
FORGOTTEN IMMEDIATELY SO THEY
CAN GO BACK TO -- VIOLENCE
ACROSS OUR NATION.
WE SHOULD NOT LET THAT HAPPEN.
HE WAS NOT THE ONLY VICTIM, BY
THE WAY, OF THE RIOTS, AND THAT
HAS BEEN FORGOTTEN.
WE THINK THAT’S A SHAME.
ON TWITTER, THIS WRITER HAS BEEN
KEEPING TRACK OF THE CASUALTIES
OF THIS RIOTING AND WE WANT TO
READ SOME OF THEM TO YOU BECAUSE
IT’S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED.
MORE THAN JUST ONE.
MANY.
DAVID PATRICK UNDERWOOD WAS A
FEDERAL PROTECTIVE SERVICE
OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA.
A WEEK AGO HE WAS SHOT TO DEATH.
WE DON’T KNOW WHO KILLED HIM.
HE WAS PROTECTING A FEDERAL
BUILDING IN OAKLAND.
ONE OF HIS COLLEAGUES WAS ALSO
CRITICALLY INJURED IN THAT
SHOOTING.
KELLY WAS JUST 22 YEARS OLD.
SHE WAS ATTENDING A GEORGE FLOYD
RELATED PROTEST IN DAVENPORT,
IOWA.
SHE BEGAN GETTING UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THE DIRECTION OF THAT
PROTEST, UNDERSTANDABLY.
SHE GOT IN HER CAR TO LEAVE AND
WAS KILLED BY A STRAY BULLET.
SHOT DEAD.
JOSE GUTIERREZ WAS A BYSTANDER,
WATCHING OTHERS LOOT A STORE IN
CICERO.
FOR BEING THERE HE WAS SHOT IN
THE HEAD AND KILLED BY THIS MAN.
THAT IS WHAT POLICE SAY.
ANOTHER VICTIM IN ILLINOIS WAS
THIS MAN, 27, SHOT TO DEATH
OUTSIDE OF A GROCERY STORE.
NO ONE REMEMBERS HIS NAME, WE
SHOULD.
IN MINNEAPOLIS, FRANCISCO, WHO
IS 46, WAS FOUND DEAD NEXT TO A
BURNED-OUT CAR.
POLICE ATTRIBUTED HIS DEATH TOO
COMPLEX, HOMICIDAL VIOLENCE.
THAT’S OBVIOUS.
AT LEAST THREE PEOPLE WERE
MURDERED DURING THE VIOLENCE IN
INDIANAPOLIS.
ONE WAS FORMER INDIANA FOOTBALL
PLAYER CHRIS BEATTY.
HE WAS FOUND SHOT TO DEATH JUST
OUTSIDE HIS APARTMENT.
AN UNNAMED LATINO MAN IN HIS
20s WAS ALSO KILLED ON SUNDAY
IN LOS ANGELES IN AN AREA THAT
WAS COMPLETELY DEMOLISHED BY
RIOTERS.
AND THOSE ARE JUST THE ONES WHO
WAS KILLED.
PROBABLY NOT AN EXHAUSTIVE LIST.
THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN HURT, MAIM,
FINANCIALLY RUINED, BRAIN DAMAGE
OVER THE PAST WEEK.
DOZENS OF THOSE ARE POLICE
OFFICERS.
THEY WERE INJURED TRYING TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
ONE OF THEM IS LAS VEGAS POLICE
OFFICER, HE WAS SHOT DURING THE
RIOT ON MONDAY.
THE MAN WHO SHOT HIM SAID IT WAS
AN ACCIDENT.
HE WAS TRYING TO SCARE AWAY
RIOTERS.
WE DON’T KNOW THE TRUTH BUT THE
MAN TOOK A BULLET TO THE HEAD,
THE POLICE OFFICER DID.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
DESERVES TO BE REMEMBERED, BUT
INSTEAD, THEY ARE FORGOTTEN AND
THEY ARE FORGOTTEN ON PURPOSE.
THE PRESS WOULD LIKE THESE
PROTESTS TO GO DOWN IN HISTORY
IS MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
THEY ARE NOT AND THEY ARE NOT,
IN PART, BECAUSE CNN, MSNBC,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND MANY
OTHERS HAVE BEEN INFLAMING
RACIAL TENSIONS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
THEY.
THEY ARE INCITING VIOLENCE.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES.
THE REST OF US SHOULD CARE.
THERE ARE HUMAN BEINGS, THEIR
AMERICAN, AND NOW THEY ARE GONE.
AND YOU KNOW WHO DID IT?
THE PEOPLE ON THE STREET, THEY
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT THEY DID.
WELL, FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS YOU
REMEMBER, OUR LEADERS MADE IT
ILLEGAL FOR YOU TO PROTEST
ANYTHING.
EVEN TO GO TO CHURCH.
THE CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWN!
BUT NOW THAT OUR STREETS ARE
OVERRUN WITH BLACK LIVES MATTER
PROTESTS AND RIOTS, THEY’VE
CHANGED THEIR MIND.
YOUR PROTESTS ARE STILL ILLEGAL,
THEY ARE RACIST.